good evening tonight we have the
pleasure of hearing from Anthony Esalen
Anthony Esalen is professor of English
at Providence College in Providence
Rhode Island a graduate of Princeton
University
he received his MA and PhD in English
from the University of North Carolina a
senior editor for touchstone a journal
of mere christianity
dr. Esalen is a regular contributor to
crisis magazine catholic world report
public discourse Magnificat and several
other journals he is the author of more
than a dozen books including Luke Reyes
Durham naturae thoracoscopy a Jerusalem
delivered irony's of faith the laughter
at the heart of Christian literature and
ten ways to destroy the imagination of
your child
he has also published a three-volume
translation of Dante's Divine Comedy a
translation that is widely read on our
campus and is a part of just about every
rhetoric and great books course an
important class in our core curriculum
in addition to these publications he is
also I'm sorry he has filmed 24 video
lectures for a three-course set on Dante
with st. Benedict Press
please join me everyone in welcoming dr.
Anthony Aslam
thank you all thank you
Thank You Daniel Thank You Rebecca I've
been wanting to visit Hillsdale College
for a long time and now I know why you
guys have paid for a certain number of
pizzas at the Esalen household with the
royalties from Dante that I have known
about I've known about you for a long
time and admired and I hope to get to
know even more about that in the next
couple of days I want you to know that I
did not choose that the subject of this
talk I was asked to come here to give a
talk on what is epic which occasions
some head-scratching on my part what do
I know about that the actual title of my
talk here tonight is as high as the
heavens are above the sea and in case
there's anybody from the New York Times
here that is a reference to the Old
Testament
which is the first half of the Bible
some years ago I got into a rather tense
conversation with a couple of students
in the office of my English department
we were talking about the Lord of the
Rings dr. Berger is up there I believe
we're talking about the Lord of the
Rings and I remarked that nothing like
it could be written now because our
culture you have to forgive me for using
that word for want of a better word I
use the word culture to describe our
mass habits after the reality of culture
has withered away whatever it is no
longer possesses a vision of the world
and of man that would sustain such a
work talking himself could write his
trilogy only because he was something of
an anachronism he was steeped in the
medieval epics the sagas of Snorri
Sturluson from iceland the finnish
Kalevala the knee belong in the eat
Beowulf
so forth and he was a devout Catholic
seeing all things by the light of
Revelation and 3,000 years of meditation
upon the ways of God to men now the
students resisted this no youngster
likes to hear that he lives in an age of
decline and decrepitude now I imagine
for instance that Dave Bing thinks that
he's the mayor of the city sorry I do
crazy things about Detroit I've never
visited them but over the years I've
grown more and more convinced that my
hunch was correct not only about the
decrepitude the the policy of the soul
that mistakes easy cynicism for
sophistication and cold-hearted lust for
love consider that ringing verse from
the prophet Isaiah for my ways are not
your ways nor are my thoughts your
thoughts saith the Lord for as high as
the heavens are above the sea so far are
my ways from your ways and my thoughts
from your thoughts that is a verse that
would set Homer himself to thinking it
expresses the vast distance
the divine in the human but it is also
addressed to man
it is clarion call for man to set out on
a journey to cross that distance even as
God Himself reaches out to man in the
events of human life the sentiment on
the part of the profit is not despair
but fear and wonder he hears the appeal
of an adventure in being itself the
sense of adventure is everywhere to be
found in the Jewish wisdom writers as
the deer longs for the running stream so
my soul longs for you my God says the
psalmist there we have the inner
adventure of the spirit and we needn't
confine ourselves to the scriptures we
have the farmer Hesiod stretching his
mind to sing of the birth of the gods
we have Pierre in his tattered clothes
Tolstoy spear retreating with his fellow
Russians from the Battle of Borodino
given a vision of the meaning of human
life by the simplicity of a large
hearted peasant but elsewhere in the
Psalms it is written the stone which the
builders rejected has become the
cornerstone by the Lord has this been
done it is wonderful in our eyes and
there we have the outer adventure of
history seeing not as one damn thing
after another and report I think said it
but as providentially led with real
surprises that finally makes sense for
instance we have the chosen people that
small and otherwise unremarkable nation
becoming a blessing to all the world
that's what the promise was to father
Abraham father of many we have st. Peter
any Polish people here that's all
in Michigan why I thought I would have a
lot we have st. Peter in Henriques and
cabbages Quo Vadis
have you ever read Sienkiewicz Polish
people
it's a matter for you it's like an
Italian not reading don t you have to
read some cottage st. Peter conquering
the Rome that would crucify him
I dare say even an agnostic must admit
the possibility someday someday a
photograph of Mother Teresa standing in
Missouri between a CAD and a hag will
cause people to say yes I never
suspected it at the time but the really
important and revolutionary figure in
this scene was that little nun from
Albania not the president which one was
he and his wife so I suggest you now
that the inner and the outer adventures
the adventure of the Spirit and the
outer adventure of history in the epoch
are one rather that the world crossing
adventure of an Aeneas or an Odysseus is
dependent upon is expressive of the
spirits soaring adventure of the human
heart answering the call of what
transcends it the epic is then
essentially theological the epic is vast
requires a vast field as vast as the sea
sailed by Ahab that tormented theologian
and captain of despair as vast as heaven
and the deep tract of Hell as vast as
the love that moves the Sun and the
other stars now if I'm right about this
then we may draw some implications about
what might otherwise look like
adventitious features of the epic but
what are really to be expected given its
theological soul and I will talk about
three such features of the epic today
and the first is this we must listen to
the muse it's a common place to treat
the epic invocation to the muse as a
commonplace - something that's done
stuck on - the opening of a long poem as
a brand name it announces here followeth
an epic
that would be a mistake I think and one
of the signs that we don't have a
genuine epic it's the demotion of the
Gods to poetic machinery and the
demotion of the invocation to a mere
formula consider the opening to poem I
don't know if anybody here knows this
one this is an early Italian Renaissance
epic romance luigi poochie's more ghonte
he begins this way in the beginning was
the word and the Word was God and the
Word was with God in my opinion it's a
brilliant opening polcie has invoked God
himself in the mystery of the
Incarnation with propriety and
irrelevance to the rest of his poem
which goes on to relate to us the crazy
feats of knights and sorcerers and
especially Giants all marauding across
Europe that's just as it seems in as
much greater imitator Ariosto seems
about as big as a comfortable county
with a couple of towns in it but what
happens if we do take the invocation
seriously I hear how Homer opens the
Iliad and I got to apologize for my
wretched Greek here anyway first line
and word of the Iliad meinen aida a ah
la la oh school luminaid translate
literally more or less in Greek word
order the rage sing goddess of Achilles
son of Peleus the dreadful rage we have
here a work of consummate artistry we've
hardly gotten to the second line rage in
the accusative case begins the poem it
is it's controlling theme the adjective
that marks its horror also in the
accusative case begins the second line
aw woman ain't hung out on it alone as
it were acting as the end bracket for
the clause rage at one and dreadful at
the other what's
in the middle then divinity is in the
middle we have a singing goddess an
Achilles born of the goddess Thetis
fetus and the mortal King Pelias now
these are not just metrical placeholders
Achilles is deals a Hillis divine
Achilles sky bright Achilles as the
final line of the opening passage of
firms but in what does his divinity
consist he's fleet of foot and strong of
arm he is a terror in battle his mother
Thetis advises him and acts as his
advocate before Zeus but the god to whom
Achilles is most pointedly compared in
the Iliad not fetus the goddess and not
Zeus the glorious and cunning but Hades
death the implacable according to Hesiod
the muses daughters of Zeus begotten
after he defeated the Titans and through
strength and farsightedness consolidated
his power and Olympus those muses confer
upon men the gift of eloquence in the
service of straight judgment they are
the inspiring powers that found the
polis but in the Iliad Achilles turns
from defending the army against the
effects of Agamemnon's avarice and
insecurity now we start the poem he
turns from that to abandoning the polis
that is the army to abandoning it
sulking in his tent and gloating when
his fellow Greeks are moan down by
Hector even the appeals of three chosen
speakers fail and who are these speakers
Ajax not brilliant but the next
strongest of the Greek warriors Phoenix
surrogate father to Achilles who pleads
on behalf of Achilles self-interest and
who reminds him of all he did for him
when he was young and Odysseus most
eloquent who actually places words of
warning upon the lips of Achilles aged
father Pelias spoken just before the lad
was to leave for the war each of these
men represents an appeal to Achilles to
reintegrate himself into a social world
one that is held together by gratitude
and piety that is due reverence to the
gods and to men of authority like his
own father Pelias Achilles heart is
moved but his will does not budge
humanity and divinity are both at issue
here
Achilles rage is superhuman in its
intensity and inhuman in its
inflexibility he is like a god but like
the wrong God somehow he must move from
Hades to Zeus or at least to a distant
reflection of Zeus from the rage to the
singing news from the man who dragged
the body of Hector three times around
the walls of Troy in the sight of Hecuba
his mother and Andromache his wife from
that too the man who gives that body
back to prime in the end King Priam old
and weak who enters Achilles in the
tenth one night and appears to him Homer
doesn't tell us how appears to him like
a god
now that I'd say is a fruitful way to
hear the invocation to confirm us in our
course the great poets who followed
Homer come forth to testify let's look
at the end of Milton's second invocation
in Paradise Lost
this is his glorious address to the holy
light of heaven the poet has dared to
venture down the Dark Descent to hell
but now his task is even more arduous
far beyond his native powers he must
speak of heaven hence Milton place for
the first time upon his own blindness
this is most fitting since sinful man
cannot penetrate the darkness of heaven
dark with excess of bright as Milton
puts it sinful man is in this sense no
healthier than the blind poet who cannot
enjoy the sight of flocks or herds or
the the greatest humanistic phrase in
all of English literature human face
divine can't see it
wisdom itself milton says is that one
entrance quite shut out but the more
profound entrance of the soul remains so
milton prays so much the rather thou
celestial light shine inward and the
mind through all her powers irradiate
their plant eyes all miss from thence
purged and dispersed that I may see and
tell of things invisible to mortal sight
just as Homer had done milton locates in
his invocation the essence of the epic
it isn't simply that the motifs of
vision and blindness are convenient for
his purposes the very temptation that
meets man in the fall is a temptation of
vision says Satan accusing God of Envy
he knows that in the day ye eat thereof
your eyes that seem so clear yet are dim
shall perfectly be then opened and
cleared and he shall be as God's knowing
both good and evil as Veda but when Adam
and Eve having sinned and then sealed
their guilt with licentiousness sleep
they soon found their eyes how dark and
how open sorry and their minds how
darkened innocence that as a veil had
shattered them from knowing ill was gone
just confidence and native righteousness
and on naked left to guilty shame he
covered but his robe uncovered more for
this central not only to the meaning of
the poem but to its very narrative
structure that vision holiness and
genuine love are all mutually
inseparable sin darkens the mind and
blinds the eye hence Satan is literally
envious his sight is invidious wrong
side out as when he's spying upon Adam
and Eve he overhears the lovers
reminiscing by the way if anybody's ever
I know that there are a lot of
homeschooled kid
said Patrick Henry College Patrick's at
Hillsdale what we were talking about
Patrick Henry in Hillsdale a few minutes
ago and sometimes I see people as they
react to homeschooled kids and the
attraction of the beauty is irresistible
the sooner they long for it my gosh how
how how did you end up with kids who are
so sweet who are so happy while others
say yes but wait till they're teenagers
that is a good case of envy and it's
what Satan does when he overhears the
innocent adamantly talking about when
they first met aside and they start
kissing after they talk because they ran
out of things to say in Easter kissing
Adam and Eve were not first created in
the Middle East but in Italy you don't
know this but
and this is Satan or Milton describing
Satan aside the devil turned for nd yet
with jealous leer malign hide them
askance and to himself thus plain sight
hateful sight tormenting thus these two
in Paradise and one another those arms
the happier Eden shall enjoy their fill
of bliss on bliss whilst I to hell and
thrust and so forth he's filled with
pride therefore he cannot love cannot
love
therefore he sees but he does not see
now hear me we may follow milton one
step farther and still remain well
within the understanding of the ancient
Greek poets I think if we invoke the
muses or the Holy Spirit that is
Milton's news then in a real way we are
confessing that our art is not simply
our own what shall it profit a man if
the muse sang and he heed her not the
attitude of the epic poet then is
mysteriously receptive Milton suggests
as much when in the prologue to book
nine that's where everything goes to
smash he confesses that his wing will
droop too low for the great flight that
remains to him if all his art were
merely his and not hers who brings it
nightly to my ear that is not a courtly
nod to a pleasant fiction and here
considered torquato tasso x' invocation
in the second stanza of his epic
jerusalem may Liberata jerusalem
delivered o muse who do not weave a
garland of the fading laurel fronds of
Helicon but far in heaven among the
death among the Blessed choirs Reed
deathless stars into a golden crown
breathe into my heart the fire of
heavenly love illuminate my song Milton
has followed Tasos lead here the old
muses who danced upon Helicon were empty
dreams milton says but the true in
heavenly muse is a poetic representation
of the Holy Spirit breathe into my heart
the fire of heaven in love Christ ah so
and we err badly if we do not take him
precisely at his word the whole of his
epic concerns that very love the
conquest of Jerusalem is Tasos metaphor
for the union within one man one woman
of the faculties of reason and appetite
and famos high-spirited drive the head
the belly in the chest as CS Lewis
following Plato put it so well it's also
a metaphor for the communion of men with
one another manifest in the army
commanded by God for who young neither
unionism is possible apart from the love
of God both subjectively and objectively
understood that is the gracious love
that is God's gift to us and the
receptive love whereby we answer him but
him who has ears to hear hear now the
second lesson follows from this first
pay attention to the muse the second
lesson because the muse brings knowledge
we cannot attain on our own the epoch
continually bursts the boundaries of our
common experience theology and
epistemology unites the metaphor for
this limit testing is naturally a voyage
or a pilgrimage it is a journey in space
or time when it's time usually into the
deep backward and a Bizen of time and
hence the association of the muse with
memory it's a voyage that reflects the
depths fathomed or the heights scaled by
the soul the Voyager we immediately
think of is Odysseus and here it's well
to look at the opening line of Homer's
other epic the Odyssey and again I got
to apologize for my Greek and Roman epic
mosa
polu tripping Haas mala Pola plank Fay
again translating with painful
literalness that man to me sing thou
amuse him of many turnings who suffered
many evils here too the first word is a
touch tone Andra the man in the
accusative case the man the real deal
the pattern of manhood that man
is polluter paws full of ships The
Artful Dodger it's a good way to
translate that word I think
Odysseus capacity to fake left and run
right shows that he's a worthy favorite
of the sly goddess Athena herself sprung
from the head of cunning Zeus master
tactician but this is also on his
mother's side kin to Hermes the patron
of Thieves
but is his crafty in various senses of
the word
he is knowledge in his hands he planes
the beams to build his boat on Calypso's
island knows just how to peg them
together how to [ __ ] up the chinks and
when he handles his famous bow in Ithaca
he strings it in one swift motion of
skill and strength and he plucks the
string makes it sing out like a swallow
as if he were a master of the harp his
knowledge in his speech knows exactly
what to say to the lovely girl
now sicka are on that tense moment on
the beach
to hold her eyes to his eyes right so
she will not look down upon his
nakedness he is neither abject nor
arrogant either skulking nor aggressive
now Sikka
turns to her playmates and says laughing
at their fear haven't you ever seen a
man before the answer to that question
is of course no they never have seen
Sean Connery don't you think it would
may have made a good odysseus in it ah
they never have seen a man before and
neither has Nausicaa they've seen
imitations but never the real thing all
this know-how is a gift of the gods but
it is yes has come to know things also
that the gods cannot really know not the
same way he knows suffering the gods can
use strategy to get their way Odysseus
must use it merely to survive his life
though it is overseen by Athena is
deeper and more fascinating than
anything the pagan goddess can in her
own right ever experience
Zeus may well weep over the death of his
own sons are Peden on the battlefield of
Troy but there's always the nectar and
ambrosia to smooth away the grief not to
mention the tumble in the hay with any
female creature of his liking and
Ganymede too right
thus does home are encouraged in us in
the Odyssey a certain ambivalence toward
the ease of the gods and their gift of
prosperity to mortal men the case of
Menelaus is instructive Menelaus arrived
too late to avenge his brother
Agamemnon's death one day too late his
journey to Egypt after the war was
mercantile he did not map the minds of
many as Odysseus did he mourns the loss
of his friend Odysseus but he's not
lifted one finger to find him all of his
protests to Telemachus
/ couched in the conditional I would do
this I would do that and just when he
and the boy think of Odysseus and begin
to weep silent tears along comes the
person who wears the Greaves in the
family Helen to slip a narcotic into
their drinks so that they could sit
calmly and cheerfully even if a brother
should be slaughtered before their eyes
the journey of Odysseus then is
existential not just geographical it is
a journey through suffering it defines
him as the man and though the suffering
sharply distinguishes him from the gods
it is also not wholly in his own power
either to embrace or to conquer it from
this point of view his journey to the
far north to speak to the shades from
the younger world is the Perim
paradigmatic adventure of the poem
Agamemnon betrayed by his wife
Clytemnestra the sister of Hell and of
course there is a family reunion I don't
want to be invited to him right he
recommends that it is exercise caution
when he returns to ethica though says
that bitter old chief Penelope will no
doubt prove to be a paragon of faithful
women as opposed to the [ __ ] he married
so there are strategic reasons why
Odysseus consults the shades but Homer
won't leave it at that
Odysseus meets Achilles and he flatters
him Achilles what glory it must be for
you to be the greatest among the
Warriors here but Achilles who could not
combine in one life military glory and
the joy of living with his family in his
homeland replies he'd rather be a
servant to a Plowman up above manuring
the fields than to be Lord of all the
gibbering shades below Odysseus meets
Ajax whom he drove mad when he won by
cunning the arms of the dead Achilles
and Ajax will not forgive him or even
speak to him he meets his mother who
died not of old age or disease but of
grief for him Odysseus her beloved son
then he sees one after another the
virtuous women of old he is in awe of
Odysseus for a moment or two with this
knowledge coming to him from without
right
Odysseus seems small to us by comparison
for a moment or two I won't say that
Odysseus learns enough from these
experiences to become a nutritious one
who achieves the knowledge of the blind
at APIs at Colonus Oedipus who says and
I think here we approach the Christian
revelation as closely as any pagan poet
did that the secret of human knowledge
is love even that Oedipus at Colonus is
still the old Oedipus cursing his
prodigal son Polynices
no slaying the fatted calf here just as
Odysseus determines to slay the noble am
finem as' when he gets back to Ithaca
even though that lad treats the beggar
king with respect but Odysseus
adventures hold out for us the ideal man
who has entered upon the threshold of a
world beyond the ultimate boundary death
and returns to tell us what he has seen
at least some of it anyway
in this regard to other epic poets have
understood the principle Lucretia's
wishing to grace his rather bad
philosophy with the glory of epic casts
his master Epicurus as a warrior general
who shatters the boundaries of the
unmeasured all and returns in a Roman
triumph other generals bring back slaves
plunder but says Lucretia's our that
their returns with knowledge of what can
arise what cannot what law grants each
thing its own deep driven boundaries
stone and finite scope religion thus
lies trampled beneath our feet and we
are made gods by the victory setting
aside the over praise this trampling of
superstition in Lucretia's mind is a
deeply religious thing it merits for
Epicurus the praise of an ultimate hero
far greater than the praise that is due
to Hercules suppose that a benefactor of
mankind
naturally the idea of a quest for
knowledge especially supramundane
knowledge was convened congenial to
Christian poets their heaven is not the
Sencha list oasis of the [ __ ] but
the beatific vision the sight of God
here if we turn to Dante we may see a
progression from what the sinner knows
which is little and dimly to what the
human mind may know through its own
powers though with assistance to what
the human mind can only come to know by
means of divine love the love that is a
free act of God from without in an
infused virtue or power from within so
near the beginning of his epic the
inferno as he prepares himself for the
arduous journey down to hell
full of arduous journeys in this paper
here never used the word arduous twice
in a paper I see him just on that Dante
invokes the muse but its abrupt its
ambiguous
he says o Musa o Alto Ingenio or my you
taught a romantic history vesti choco VD
quick see para lat what no Billy today o
mules oh hi genius now come to my
assistance Oh mind who wrote down what I
saw here your nobility will appear
dungeon translating loosely here the
muses renamed twice in quick succession
she's the alto and Jo in the main day
she's the high or the deep indwelling
genius his native powers and the mind
that wrote down what Dante saw it
appears that Dante is calling on his own
muse here as if he were announcing that
he's about to crack his poetic knuckles
stretching mind and craft to their
limits to show their nobility to the
world but when he opens the purgatory Oh
Dante compares his genius to a little
boat sailing upon the sea
Lana Beach Ella del mu Ingenio ingenuity
again but now it's not each Ella Oh
the boat now the sea figures prominently
at the beginning of purgatory souls have
to be ferried across from the mouth of
the Tiber clear to the other end of the
world to them to the shores of the
mountain of Purgatory's it's exactly
opposite the globe from Calvary these
are waters Dante says he is alluding to
his miss adventurous voyage of Ulysses
in Inferno 26 these are waters that no
man ever sailed who lived to tell it in
his native land the sea would overwhelm
his little ship of ingenuity were it not
for the muse who is now a goddess to
whom Dante owes allegiance Dante had
traveled down into the realm of death
now he must climb a mountain of life
that brings healing
no man can mount its slopes without the
grace of God that grace is akin to the
favor of the muses whom Dante now calls
holy as breathe is an Italian if you
don't mind and then a translation
McQueen la morte [ __ ] race or God
Oh Santa Moos a Provost Rosana a quick
alley-oop al cuento circa seg wheat and
milk on token quail suono d qu e d PK
miserly sentir el loco poco que esperar
perdona he rise to life again
dead poetry l'amour topo see racer de
let it oh holy muses for I am yours and
hear Calliope strike a hierarchy
accompanying my song with that sweet air
which made the wretched Magpies feel a
blow that turned all hope of pardon to
despair the Magpies daughters of the
this alien King Pyrrhus challenged
Calliope to a singing match they lost
and they were for their presumption
transformed into those big gaudy
European cousins of our squawking blue
jays Magpies the word despair here
suggest that the defeat is spiritual the
daughters of Paris so to speak lost
their souls when they lost the contest
they toss their souls away when they
embarked presumptuously upon the contest
they're like the Ulysses of the inferno
who gave his men evil counsel wetting
their appetite to sail beyond the bounds
set four on assisted human knowledge and
the participle is it crucial their
Ulysses is correct to suggest them that
it is natural in men to seek to know
what transcends man he says to them
consider Adela vostra Samantha farting
on frosty Aviva coming booty ma para
seguir very cute a a conscience I think
well on your be getting and your seed
you were never made to live like brutes
but to pursue the good in mind indeed
but the problem is that Ulysses does not
seek to receive this knowledge as a gift
the implicit lie in what he says is that
the vast ocean is before him isn't he
and no different from a stream that a
boy may cross by stepping on stones the
one may be crossed with ease the other
with great trouble and risk and cunning
but both may be crossed in a sense the
presumption of Dante's Ulysses belies a
fundamental contradiction the
epistemological aim is vast seems to be
vast anyway when suddenly the heavens
collapse and the great voyage is no
different in kind from a trip from
Central Park to the Lower East Side with
the exception that the latter may be
more dangerous certain hours of the
night the spirit of Hesiod rather and
I'm suggesting the spirit of Homer Homer
Zone Odysseus or of the ever searching
Socrates in the Phaedrus and the
symposium that spirit approaches that of
Dante when he prays for wisdom and for
poetic genius as unmerited gifts the
invocation to the epic muezzin purgatory
becomes in Paradise a prayer to Christ
the wisdom of God the true Apollo says
Dante
oh good Apollo for this last work of art
make me as fit a vessel of your power as
you demand when you bestow the crown of
the beloved Laurel till this hour one
peak of twin Parnassus has suffice
if I am to enter the lists now I shall
need both then surge into my breasts and
breathe your song as when you drew the
vein Marcia's from the sheath of his own
limbs please keep in mind that image of
the arena of battle I'm returning to it
soon there are two things I wish to
point out here the first is Dante's
prayer for the breath of Apollo and
thornell pet dome ooh he says enter my
breast thinking of the Sybil in Virgil's
Aeneid
seized by the God and compelled to speak
his words a spirit to it and breathe
yours that is breathe your power breathe
your knowledge breathe your song we must
not leave the breathing behind to think
of some vague inspiration as when people
say they're inspired by a fireman
singing the national anthem meaning that
they feel modestly uplifted and are glad
for firemen who can sing the breathing
recalls Genesis when God formed Adam
from the dust and breathed into him the
breath of life and he became a living
soul the breathing here is to make Dante
new it is to affect what is parodied by
the punishment of Marsyas that sorry
satyr had challenged Apollo to a musical
duel and lost
he's therefore analogous to the Magpies
at the beginning of purgatory but
Marsyas was not condemned to shrieking
at crows he was d vagine' ated
unsheathed from his own members
literally he was flayed alive but Dante
too wishes to be unsheathed from his own
limbs at least in a certain sense
he wishes to be unbound from the
limitations of the flesh he calls this
transformation to resume and our trans
human ears I put it man's soaring beyond
man it elevates man to godhood yet in
another sense he does not wish to be
unbound from the flesh because following
those cryptic words of Job he wishes to
see his Redeemer in the flesh with his
own eyes not in others
even in his ascent to paradise he'll not
deny the possibility that he was raised
both in the soul and in the body
he says if I bore alone that part of me
which you created last oh love that
steers the heavens you surely know for
your light lifted me there it is he did
not raise himself he was raised by the
love that steers the heavens on his own
Dante is as he'll say at the culmination
of his voyage and his vision and his own
he's no better than a baby who wets his
tongue still at his mother's breast most
obviously those words allude to Mary
seat of wisdom whose intercession Dante
has entreated but they remind us also
what he believes the true voyage of
poetry and knowledge is all about so
spacious and purgatory describes homer
as the Greek who drank most deeply at
the muses breast star in a station that
Virgil who says that and again I think
we'd be wrong to consider that line to
be a mere nod to convention it expresses
the epic thirst for knowledge which
comes from beyond the self beyond man
alone and yet there's a way in which the
analogy to the baby is not adequate
either as Dante well knew when in the
quest of the Holy Grail Cistercian epic
romance of the 12th century Sir Galahad
sir Bors and sir Percival get on board
the ship of faith they consigned
themselves entirely to the direction of
God this is well symbolized by the fact
that the ship has no tiller
its sails we're Providence takes it so
far they might all be babes at the
mother's breast except that they're all
courageous and tireless warriors to the
Word of God says the writer to the
Hebrews is a two-edged sword piercing to
the quick Abel of dividing soul and
spirit and discerning the intents of men
those three good Knights bear the sword
of the word of God the unknown
Cistercian author of their epic
narrative makes them at once receptive
as babes the best and active in the
field of battle and in the field of
knowledge adventures come to them that's
what the word adventure means something
that happens to
it comes in your path and that might
lead us to think of them as mere blanks
upon which are inscribed the plans of
God yet they are in ventures indeed in
our sense of the word battles against
wicked knights sorcerers and demons and
voyages toward the vision of what I has
not seen nor has it entered into the
mind of man to conceive namely the
direct vision of Christ in the Eucharist
here the two characteristics I've named
point us toward the third the epic is
fundamentally theological it is
epistemologically receptive especially
of knowledge beyond the unaided capacity
of man to discover therefore it
naturally takes us into battle
that is why Dante at the beginning of
Paradise says he must enter the lists it
is not simply a commonplace he who would
save his life must lose it says Jesus
and that well expresses what we might
call the law of the epic battle it has a
law not arbitrarily imposed by God it is
implied by the very nature of man's
attempt to approach the divine by his
setting forth on a voyage for that
divine knowledge death must need stand
between us and rebirth the man who does
not risk all risks nothing except his
chance to find all and see all here we
may as so often rely upon Milton to see
how the battle is central to the epic
and why this is so I'm thinking of the
passage in book 9 when Milton disclaims
sole authorship or even principle
authorship of his poem and then scenes
seems to strike at the heart of the
whole epic tradition he's going to
describe the fault man in the wrath of
heaven sad task he says yet argument not
less but more heroic than the wrath of
stern Achilles on his foe pursued thrice
fugitive about Troy wall so much for the
Iliad yet note that he does grant that
that poem is heroic or age of Ternes for
Lavinia dis espoused or Neptune's ire or
Juno
that so long perplexed the Greek and
Syria's son so much for Virgil's Aeneid
if answerable style I can obtain of my
celestial patroness who Danes her
nightly visitation unemployed and
dictates to me slumbering or inspires
easy my unpremeditated verse astonishing
description that is astonishing what it
feels like for a great artist to be
visited with images or ideas or words or
music from beyond the self continue
since first this subject for heroic song
pleased me long choosing and beginning
late not sedulous by nature to indict
wars hitherto the only argument heroic
deemed chief mastery to dissect with
long and tedious havoc fabled Knights in
battles feigned the better fortitude of
patience and heroic martyrdom unsung
seems that battle does not make the epic
Milton's eyes but epic demands the
battle Milton may have in mind here the
most arid stretches of Ariosto whom
otherwise he admired and profited by
canto upon canto describing the feats of
knights such as never lived fighting the
Saracens in a battle for Paris which
never took place with all the tilting
furniture of lances and helmets and war
horses and breastplates and bannered
tents and trumpets that's an injustice
to reo Stowe but a glance toward
Milton's favorite English poet Spenser
sage and serious Spenser will illuminate
us here the knight of temperance this
admit what Milton says in Areopagitica
is this defense of a reasonably Free
Press the knight of temperance in
Spenser's Faerie Queene is not is not
somebody who hides away from the battle
he's not a puppet Adam and Adam in a
puppet show but a man who enters the
lists not without dust and heat and
faces head-on the temptations of the
world
Spenser's Faerie Queene as milton surely
saw was filled with that tilting
furniture of jousting that he has just
now derided but
always in the service of what milton
calls the better fortitude in other
words milton's rejection of the epic
tradition is not based on any pacifism
or on any dismissal of the manly call to
fight Milton wants not less fighting
he wants more the problem is that a war
between Mycenae and Troy is not enough
of a war the battlefield must be
decisive no unit says st. Paul that we
strive against powers and principalities
no less than the whole of man body
spirit soul past and present and future
the temporal in the eternal is at stake
the epic hero then is to use Milton's
term a martyr a fighting witness to the
truth that has come to him from beyond
his natural Ken that definition may shed
light even upon the heroes of the pagan
epics Virgil his cherry of words he
doesn't allow us much leisure to dwell
upon the turbulence of Aeneas heart but
if we do pause to notice it we see a man
seeking to perform his duty in the
twilight of human passions and
misunderstandings a man who learns as he
moves from one unhappy incident to
another just what the gods require of
him Aeneas has not only to fight Ternes
he has to fight Aeneas he is not the
fury ridden young Achilles he's a man
slightly past his prime whose wisdom is
hard-won and bitter few sadder words
have ever been written than those Virgil
put on the lips of this man as he
prepares for his final battle against
Turnus having already conquered his
dearest desires he says to his son dis
scape who erred of br-2 next may their
own quail Abhiram fortuna mcsally's
laborer and man who'd learned from me my
son good fortune you can learn from
someone else and he is a conflicted
martyr to what remains at the end of the
poem an unresolved riddle the virtue of
piety which embraces duty to the Father
and the household gods and the great
gods and which Virgil has tried and I
believe failed to integrate with
see to all those who suffer in this dark
and baffling world but the epic demands
no less than all were it not for our
knowledge of Achilles dreadful dilemma
he may win everlasting glory on the
battlefield but then must die young
never to see his homeland or his father
again were not for that we would see his
fury in the war as no more admirable
than that of a butcher
Achilles witnesses wrongly I believe to
the transcendent worth of that glory is
why Galahad must die gratefully yet
still as a martyr as soon as he behold
mysteries of the Grail is why Spencer's
Red Cross night in both nights of his
three-day battle against the dragon
undergoes a symbolic death raised to
life again
first by the water of the well of life
and then by but by the balm of the tree
of life so that that puzzled pollute of
a beast that dragon on the morning of
the third day morning of the third day
for those of you from the washington
post that says reference to the new
testament that dragon wonders whether
it's the same night he's been fighting
or some night newborn it's why if
Beowulf had ended with the wrestling
match between the gate and the monster
with Beowulf locking him in a
half-nelson
ripping his arm off giving our poet monk
the opportunity for the greatest line of
ironic understatement in anglo-saxon
poetry which I loosely translate this
way that was not a good day for Grendel
if the palm had ended their Beowulf the
man would never have attained full
heroic stature he must do more than risk
death he must die down into the realm of
death into the mirror we're old mrs.
Grendel lurks ma Grendel I should say
and in the end into the lair of the
Dragon well y'all shall must leave the
monastery and battle it out with his
half mad brother Yvonne a hab must shrug
aside the motive a prophet and search
the oceans for the white whale Dante
must enter those gates that read la sha
Tony Sparano you can throught a welcome
to Ohio the Buckeye State
didn't know that that was the state
motto
it's just they they they were
classically educated back in the day you
know abandon all hope ye who enter here
Godfrey must lay siege to Jerusalem not
be satisfied with an Edessa here or in
Antioch there he must fulfill his vow
and hang up his arms at the Church of
the Holy Sepulchre they are still to be
seen there what shall it profit a man
says Jesus if he gains the whole world
and lose his own soul he implies also
the converse what shall a man be harmed
if he lose the whole world and gain his
own soul they are the words that moved
at Francis Xavier to set all worldly
gain to the wind and voyage to India to
Japan and to lay his bones to rest on an
unknown Shore the sagas of the pagan
heroes of the north as sigrid undset
well saw any Scandinavians here
no Scandinavians or poles got to read
seaward own City those sagas prepare the
way for the sagas of saints queen of a
queen like Bridget leaving all the
perquisite sub her royalty aside and
travelling to Rome to win the Pope over
to her fight to reform the church or of
a nun schooled middle class woman like
Catherine of Siena to cast herself fully
into the works of charity and
contemplation and to move the world so
effectively that it may well be argued
that no woman of our own liberated time
wields a fraction of the influence that
Catherine wielded she too was a fighter
it's true she too was a fighter a martyr
not figuratively but in the flesh quit
alike men st. Paul writes to the
Corinthians and our dainty translators
made skittish by such open displays of
manhood and such clear affirmations of
the soldierly ideal softened the command
by rendering it merely figurative be
courageous they say
nay but quit you like man implies the AG
on the lists the arena the battlefield
the proving grounds
where we show what kind of warriors we
are if that notion is pagan it is also
Christian and Milton and Spencer and
Dante would say that it is more truly
Christian than pagan because there it is
more truly the warrior we see the man on
the quest the witness to one who
transcends all things the man laid most
open to ridicule to treachery to
disappointment to futility to death in
this regard the Christian soldier
follows the trail blazed by the master
who descended into the netherworld of
sin and it's emptiness the realm of
death and took captivity captive so that
we may sing out the words of that
apostle who surely had the soul of an
epic poet o death where is thy victory o
grave where is thy sting and he with the
soul of a warrior had the soul of a
lover too as the best of warriors have
as he looks forward to the time when he
will see not as in a glass darkly but
face to face and now we're ready I think
to consider again the discussion I had
with those students years ago when I
said that the Lord of the Rings could
not now be written because the conjurer
ease of habits instilled in us by mass
education mass marketing mass media mass
politics which we are pleased to call by
the sacred name of culture could not
sustain it
if theology proves too difficult or
threatening for the modern mind to
approach perhaps that mind may yet
concede to a hard human reality at the
beginning of his autobiographical work
witness Whittaker Chambers tries to
explain to his children to whom he's
principally addressing his work what
made him a communist what was the appeal
it was not economics it was not the
dictatorship of the proletariat it was
not the theory of history it was that
communism stirred something deep within
the human soul it gave to modern man
something for which to die
it was an evil thing he now knows but it
was something whereas the hedonist of
the West has nothing no one will die for
a house in the suburbs with a Jacuzzi in
the master bedroom no one will die for
the choice among 200 channels on the
television so then let me pose the
question as I end for what will you die
for what will you stand as a witness
staking all that you have and are even
your sacred honor as the signers of the
Declaration of Independence did and what
was no rhetorical flourish as the chest
was among us would like to believe Frodo
was willing to die for middle-earth and
the Shire Beowulf was willing to die for
the Danes he came to save and for the
glory he would gain for his fellow geeks
and for his Lord he alakh roland was
willing to die for Christ and for his
friends in battle Dante would never have
descended into the realm of death but
for the love of Beatrice Godfrey was
willing to lay down his bones in
Jerusalem here all three of my criteria
meet the object of ultimate love the
quest to attain it and the willingness
to fling life itself away as a trifle
beside it that and that alone is what
makes the epoch possible thank you
I'm told that there are questions and
answers now thank thank you very much
but at now you know if I am Italian so
if you don't ask me question I'm going
to be offended questions
way back there hmm
well you really a couple of minor of
minor ones first did you personally
prefer the Iliad or the Odyssey ha ha ha
the which translation of Jerusalem
liberated in English do you do you
consider the best that may that may seem
idle because I know you've written one
of your own and also with regard to the
evils and deniable evils of the
hedonistic culture and mass media do you
think that he didn't estate culture
really follows necessarily from the
benefits of technology and so forth or
whether it's just a mixture of them with
the entitlement mentality that may
actually come from separate sources if
it could be separated from that they
could be mitigated significantly and
that the things that caused them could
amount to something worse that could be
a basis for culture thinking of the free
market and what that requires which
involves work ok now is it so first but
could it be could that be made to can
that be saved you understand the first
question is whether I prefer the Iliad
or the Odyssey every once in a while I
go a little half mad and prefer the
Iliad I think ultimately I prefer the
Odyssey I am not entirely confident in
that choice The Odyssey is obviously
easier to teach and since I do teach in
our two year-long required of all
students a program in Western
civilization development of Western Civ
covering literature and theology and
history and philosophy and the fine arts
for two years I have to introduce
freshmen to to homer and the Odyssey is
an obvious choice it's more like Star
Wars
but it's it's also fascinating because
there's there's a great lot going in it
that is quite foreign to them but they
don't know that it's foreign to them
because the Odyssey is so approachable
the whole idea of a Greek poleis the
whole idea of Greek definition of an
idiot just what the Cyclops is not
because he has a low cyclops IQ or
because he has one eye in the center of
his head I wonder about Cyclops
flirtation you know she bats her
eyelashes but because every family
ignores its neighbors and I immediately
think of the United States of America
now that is very much so I usually
choose to introduce them to the Odyssey
but I'm not entirely comfortable about
that of course the best English
translation of Jerusalem deliver Lieber
Tata is mine then there's that's not
saying too much because they're hardly
any there is a a very wooden trance I
hope he's not here oh dear I just said
wooden I apologize but there is a there
is a prose translation which I used to
use for my students in my Spenser class
until I got fed up with it finally and
proposed to Johns Hopkins hey why don't
I translate Jerusalem in Liberata and
they said go for it boy
you've got to translate poetry as poetry
I mean it's it's it's like I I don't
know about you but I can't read reviews
of musical performances because I don't
hear the music and and translating great
poetry into prose that doesn't do it for
me the third question is is fascinating
it's whether we can I think scrub
ourselves free of some of the
dehumanizing effects of the mass
phenomenon out there if we would but
recover some of the virtues of
self-reliance and reject the what I what
I've called it just appeared in Catholic
World Report a couple of days ago but
what I called a vampire State there are
two things that you need to know about
vampires the one is that they subsist on
blood and the other is that they confer
immortality upon you but not one that
you would want wraiths like immortality
that's what the welfare state the
vampire state confers upon its citizens
if we could detach ourselves from that
we would go a good long ways towards
recovering some health but the job is
much more difficult than simply saying I
will not accept the the ministrations of
Satan the federal government we really
have to unlearn the habits of of a
mechanized oh of an over mechanized
society that is and I know when I go
back to my room tonight I am going to
check Facebook I'm not sure that's a
good thing I spent three months without
the Internet this summer and they were
glorious in some way Western man has to
learn again what it even means to have a
culture Romana Gordini any fans of
Gordini here Roman aguardiente Catholic
priest theologian philosopher writing in
1948 just after the war was already
saying that a Western man had entered a
new phase in history man without culture
saying that a night like we we need
desperately I think to recover the
fullness of what means to have a culture
to to belong with people
who shares something of your vision of
the world to give to your children
precious things from their heritage and
not scorn them as a life that is devoted
to immediate gratification inevitably
does III think we're fooling ourselves
if we think that that can happen but not
in the shadow of church right I think
those two go together inevitably and
without one the other withers I hope
that answers that that sufficiently if
not we can still talk about it
afterwards yes sir final question can't
be the final question solely though in
an age of feminist hegemony I'm so
tempted to say not in my house
haha that's a very good question
ah you know I have a I have a fortunate
position at Providence College we never
quite lost our Catholic identity that
was not exactly by design it happened
indirectly on as a result of the
institution of this Western civilization
program back in 1971 and its application
to the entire student body but once it
would attract professors who really were
interested in poetry history theology
philosophy in the fine arts and that's a
different breed okay
they tended to be practicing catholics
or christians of some sort or if not
that observant jews or if not that very
friendly to the practice of religion and
that has made a great deal of difference
it makes a great deal of difference and
in for instance what sorts of students
show up there to begin with i find and
have found for quite some time that my
students will allow me to speak frankly
about the sexes whereas my colleagues in
the English department my colleagues
would not write i my that the female
students in my class laugh uproariously
when I cast Odysseus as Sean Connery or
the other way around
I don't be interesting
they don't blink when I say that the
Gilgamesh epic shows the cultural
dynamism of the male bond forged so
often as a result of combat friendship
arising from combat and that sort of
friendship is short circuited the
possibility for this short circuited
when we say you can't fight how these
boys ever going to be friends for life
that they don't beat each other up
how many guys here in this room can
think of a close friend and your
friendship began with a fight there we
go okay they will accept that because it
rings true to them I'm finding that
we've passed a certain point at least
that province cause I may be living a
charmed life I don't know but the world
out there has nothing there's absolutely
nothing all right I mean even the women
in the class don't like feminist
literature you know who would like it it
doesn't
i-i-i-i joke with them and they allow me
do this there are only two things in the
world that feminists don't understand
men and women things that they don't
like well you know it's not actually a
lot of fun to spend most of your waking
hours with people who don't like the
human race they're open to these things
these kids these kids are thirsty and
very often introduction to great works
of art and literature is their path back
to faith I see that quite often so I
don't have that problem I don't imagine
that you guys don't have that problem at
Hillsdale so so you may lead a charmed
life too but but I think we should take
heart because eventually in a battle
between something and nothing at all
something has got win and we have more
than something but they have nothing
it's their time for another question
that's right
thank you